hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you
oh billy frustrated face today
all the frustration
the goddamn frustration i'll tell you
right now there's just not enough hours
in the day
you know do you think they do you think
they used to say that during caveman
days
yeah it's just not enough hours during
the day
now we [ __ ] slaughtered that
prehistoric [ __ ] piece of meat now we
can just sit around just eat this for
the next few days
keep your head on a swivel make sure no
saber-toothed tiger comes around we're
good good
what's the problem
it's not how it works nowadays i'll tell
you right now that just ain't how it
works um i'm trying to get to the
[ __ ] gym this week
just has not been working out
because uh you know my my car got a flat
tire
and then you know i had to get the flat
tire [ __ ] you know the tire got all
[ __ ] you know i don't know what
happened i need a front end alignment oh
jeez as we open the hood
it turns out uh then i don't know if
there was some sort of rodent in there
but it ate up some of your [ __ ] wires
jesus christ
who knew who knew there was so many
problems you know what i'll tell you
there's a goddamn cat
i don't know who owns it who who knows
who owns the [ __ ] cat right
those [ __ ] things those [ __ ]
all over the neighborhood
figured there was a nice goddamn cat
around right
the smell of the thing
would scare off the rats and the [ __ ]
mice
you know but i don't know what happened
i went back east for ten days i come
back
one of them decided to crawl up into my
if that's even what happened
i don't know what happened
but all i know is where they were
supposed to take it over there
supposed to put a new tire on the
[ __ ] rim
they supposed to put the rim back on the
car and i was supposed to be on my way
and next thing you know you know
it's like you go in for a sore throat
next thing you know they tell you you
got ass cancer
so that's what happened with the car so
i'm still waiting for the goddamn thing
you know which has been inhibiting my
ability to get over to the [ __ ] gym
and uh you know ate like a [ __ ] pig
on my vacation the first three days i
got my 10 000 steps in and then the last
[ __ ] six days i got my 10 000
calories in
and and you know
i don't give a [ __ ] what kind of math
mind you have but you know i i did not
end up on the right side of the scale
all right
am i upset with myself yes
do i wish i made some different
decisions on my vacation of course i do
do i regret it
no i don't
i don't
it was [ __ ] delicious every goddamn
calorie of it i i absolutely loved it
so
uh oh billy big britches i had a big day
yesterday
solo'd you know flew the helicopter all
by my lonesome
had a great time went through five
different [ __ ]
air spaces
landed at a busy airport there was
[ __ ] four planes in front of me the
guy turned dude [ __ ] east zero night
zero you got it you [ __ ] right i
i landed that [ __ ]
i went all the way back i had such a
good time totally relaxed i was ahead of
the aircraft the entire [ __ ] time
said one time frequency change i didn't
have it in the standby it was not a big
deal
it was not a big deal it's very hazy out
and uh which believe it or not when
there's a lot of haze out there it's
easier to see other uh
traffic that's up there
it makes no sense right
traffic that's close to you obviously
far off in the distance you can't see it
but anything that's going to be enclosed
you can see it that nice gray background
it they they stick out like a sore thumb
as opposed to a bunch of trees and
houses and pools and different colored
[ __ ]
becomes diff more difficult to see um
but i really i just had a great time
went up there did a
nice slow relaxed pre-flight
cleaned it up
you know blades were a little dirty
cleaned those up made sure everything
was great
gassed the thing up right
brought it out there
had a nice lift off you know
nice and controlled
wasn't worried about the
and four-wheeler
and off i went
off i went
didn't [ __ ] up any of my radio calls
and i gotta tell you man
you know
i don't know why they they're they're
just constantly doing these real estate
shows
at least in la it's always in uh
you know the hollywood hills
those big stupid open floor plan houses
it's an open floor plan
just feel like you're in this giant
library
um
oh my god then you can't get away from
anybody
honey
how can you ignore your wife when
there's no walls
honey i know you can hear me i can see
the side of your head
stop pretending you're asleep your eyes
were open when i first yelled it
what what what do you want
well first of all why didn't you i can't
hear you you're too far away
well there's no reason to yell at me yes
it is
yes it is you wanted 25 000 square feet
of [ __ ] open space not me this was
your idea don't say that
all right i'm sorry
sorry all right but you wanted to keep
upgrading
i was fine with the garrosh garrison
colonial in worcester massachusetts but
not you
oh
we gotta go out to the hills of beverly
they're always doing these shows about
these [ __ ] beverly hills
stupid ass [ __ ] how they all look the
exact [ __ ] same by the way
there's two stoves
two refrigerators
two ball washers there's always two of
everything
i don't know what kind of [ __ ]
parties
are are [ __ ] these super rich people
throwing that they need like
one of those viking stoves that has a
stove and then a little stove
by the way i love the little stove isn't
it [ __ ] adorable
you know
i have a stove like that it doesn't
[ __ ] work
came with the house
you know
i like the burner it goes
it lights and it just keeps going
the whole time you're making a [ __ ]
fried egg
you know i don't give a [ __ ] i had
somebody come over here some [ __ ]
weekend warrior tear up the [ __ ] in
front of it
go to fix it it worked for a while but
now it's back to doing it right
just sit there tick tick tick tick tick
you know i feel whenever it's happening
i always picture for some reason an
unshaven jack lemon in like 1960
with pajamas and a bathrobe on a slipper
as i'm making it you know
unshaven
cigarette hanging out of his mouth
you know just
that joe six-pack [ __ ] guy
that he used to play um
but anyways you have a stove with a
little stove next to it
and then you have another one so you
have four stoves
like these parties must be i mean
these [ __ ] rich people can eat
you know what's the guys eating right
all their trophy wives are on some
[ __ ] lettuce diet i'm on the lettuce
diet you just eat lettuce but i can have
as much as i want
no i don't get sad because i forget what
happy feels like but thank you for
asking
wait did i have dreams
um
i was out flying over uh
you know pasadena
el monte uh
bracket airport all the way out there
you cannot [ __ ] believe
some of the houses
up along the south greybuil mountains
and even other ones where there's just
like a little hill or something like
[ __ ] these giant pools
these people are living the life out
there i bet they paid one [ __ ] tenth
of that poor bastard who does not have a
wall to hide behind
oh nothing says divorce like an open
floor plan i mean you cannot get away
are you [ __ ] kids dad
dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what i would do if i had one of
those big stupid houses as much as i
loved my family you know you got to get
away at some point right i would have
one of the you know you know the shotgun
bed you ever seen that thing it's
[ __ ] hilarious
there's like a headboard right it's
brilliant if you live by yourself or if
you kind of want to accidentally shoot
your wife in the head
every time i saw it like the guy like
you reach back
and the headboard flips around and a
shotgun comes down
into your hand now every time i saw it
the shotgun was pointed at the person
the business end of the gun is pointed
at the person next to you
it's like why wouldn't you have that
pointed
voice is cracking why wouldn't you why
wouldn't you have that pointed to the
outside
but anyway i do love the the i mean
that's the shotgun bed is the [ __ ] i'm
sorry
if you live in the [ __ ] middle of
nowhere or maybe you've pissed off the
wrong people
i mean you know the gun under the pillow
who knows man actually blow your [ __ ]
head off
um
but what if you have a dream a vivid
dream of being on vacation you're
stretching out at the beach
what are the odds of that
i think the shotgun bed
you know what i would turn it into
because i have tinnitus
i would have tetanus however you say it
i would turn it into the paint gun bed
i don't care what anybody is coming
through the [ __ ] door with if i got a
paint gun and i'm just blasting you in
the face with paintballs
you're getting the [ __ ] out of there
you just are
you you're going to go to another what
are you going to do you're going to
commit a double murder and then walk
down the street with paint on your face
you got paint in your face
this caper is over
the [ __ ] out of here you got you got a
welted up
[ __ ] face i would have permanent
paint in there too as if there's a
such a thing
you know what a tattoo gun that's what
you want you reach back and you just
[ __ ] blast and [ __ ] ink into
somebody's face
you know what it should be too the way
it should blast it should blast your
address
do you know why we brought you in uh
yeah because of the tattooed address on
my forehead dude a tattooed gun
that's just aimed right at your [ __ ]
bedroom door
anybody who comes in there no matter
what they do they have your [ __ ]
address
and the time
more importantly the [ __ ] time
so that way they go you know he's a
practical joker i went over there for
lunch and he set it up and it
accidentally went off i've been meaning
to i've been trying to save the money up
for tattoo removal
um
anyway
i love those people that have like gun
arsenals and all of that [ __ ]
and all this home security
you know what's hilarious
is you keep it for 10 years right
and nobody breaks in
and then you got to get it upgraded
and after i would think two times of
doing that and all the money you spent
and no axe murderer having a decency to
come walking through your front door
so you can take out your [ __ ] you
know so and so over under whatever the
[ __ ] you call that over i always like
that over under i got an over under
shotgun got it over under
i'm in the face and on the balls all the
same time i'll blast your taint to your
forehead
try me right
mossberg over under
you got the side by side got the over
under i got the over and over side by
side they should make a [ __ ] they
should make one
side by side and over under like the
sign of the cross with shotgun blasts
four [ __ ] you could sell that in a
minute
in a minute put a red trump hat on it
you could retire off that
it's a side by side over under over
under side by side
any way you want it
single blow out both your shoulders your
forehead and your [ __ ] balls
clean off
be looking like some some [ __ ]
pulled pork is what it's gonna look like
with a [ __ ] belt hanging off of it
i don't know a pig could wear jeans i
ain't no pig that's a dumb [ __ ] who
walked through my goddamn bedroom door
last night how the [ __ ] you do that well
i had one of them over under side by
side what i had
i never heard of that you never heard of
that
that's the [ __ ]
you know the late night thing when they
do the uh there's always the dumb person
that doesn't get it
wait a minute you're telling me this
takes four shells it takes four shells
over 100 side by side well how does it
work i'll tell you what [ __ ] walk
through the [ __ ] dressing room door
um
anyway
it's got to be sad
like how much is ted nugent hoping that
somebody someday walks on his [ __ ]
property and it's just never happened
he's never had to shoot somebody
he's getting up there in his years he
must i wonder if he cries some nights
you know
talking to his guns
had you all these years you know
i always thought i could use you
shoot somebody's kid
when i came over the fence to get that
tennis ball
um
all right well
i'm gonna do some stand-up tonight
uh
i got some gigs this weekend
i can't stop doing that accent i'm going
down to uh
i got a gig in hollywood this weekend
hollywood california hollywood florida
baby
hollywood florida i'm going right into
the belly of the beast i'm gonna i'm
gonna get to find out if this covet is
real or not
uh where i live they think it's real out
there they think it's fake
well they don't think it's a big deal
i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna see
her what is her what
i'm like a lot of you i'm flying in i'm
going to my room i'm getting room
service i'm coming downstairs i'm doing
both [ __ ] gigs i'm going back to the
room and i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
there
all right those floridians they're
they're too tough for me
all right i ain't playing that game
i'm gonna get a rapid test before i go
back into my house if not they'll have
me tied to the back of the house like
old yeller when he was going mad
you know
there's a story kids don't have anymore
remember when our dog got rabies and dad
made me go out and shoot it
[Laughter]
is there any wonder those people beat
their kids with a belt
now what do we do i had to put my dog
down
i know that's so sad did you feel
did you feel sad
that's so bad you had to put your dogs
down
so bad and you felt sad there's all
these support groups
back in the day as an eight-year-old
you had to shoot your own [ __ ] dog
after it got after it saved your ass
from a rabid [ __ ] raccoon right
it [ __ ] saved you from one of them
varmints right and then you had to go
out
and pay it back by what putting it out
of its [ __ ] misery
oh yeller
go out there blow its [ __ ] head off
and then you had to bury the dog
come inside with the sniffles quit you
cry
quit your crowd off this [ __ ] tire
you that scarecrow you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy
you had to deal with that
going to school jealous of the kids that
could afford shoes you're sitting there
with your [ __ ] dirty feet
heard he had to shoot his dog last night
everybody tease you
johnny's got a dog
it's a [ __ ] rough time
you know what i mean
you think about how those people grew up
and then you look at what half the
people are bitching about on [ __ ]
social media
um
i had a proud day as a father
my son was at the park
uh he's playing with some other babies
and one of the kids took a toy from him
and my kid gave him a smack
and i got to tell you it did not
surprise me in the least did not
surprise anybody in my family that
that's what he did
all right
we just you just yeah
he's got a minute you know if i take him
away from something he doesn't like it
he ju he gets mad throws his back
back like arches is back as i'm holding
on to him going you can't buddy i'm
sorry you're gonna get hurt
and then he it's like he's get remember
remember uh a high five and then you had
the the ten
the double high five that's what he does
to my face he rears back and just slaps
me
on my bald head
and i try not to laugh i'm like buddy
you can't hit people like that but
inside
as a father
i like that instinct
i'm gonna get him some baby wife beaters
or whatever you're supposed to call them
now tank tops i love how you can't say
wife beat her anymore
i thought that was giving ladies the
heads up
sweetheart he's wearing a wife beater
what are you doing go meet yourself a
nice guy with a dress shirt on
what do you say only guys with tag talks
beat women yes
generally speaking i'm kidding here's
something there's a thing i do want to
talk about um people who have camaros
and mustangs
can you please take off those loud
exhausts you're not fooling anybody we
all know it's not that fast a car
coming down the [ __ ] street i can
still see you where you going
i'm not saying that that chevy and ford
don't make a fast forward or a fast
camaro it's just not the one you're
driving
that's stupid uh i got a i got a hat car
exhaust
if i was running [ __ ]
you would not be allowed to have a loud
exhaust unless what you were driving was
fast because i'm getting [ __ ] i'm
getting a little sick of that you know
with my sensitive ears there i don't
mind something [ __ ] loud
all right that's fast
fast and loud that'd be a good idea for
a tv show wouldn't it
shout out to richard rollins um
it's just when somebody has a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and they just have these
loud [ __ ] exhausts
and i've noticed that you know
there's some lower level challengers
camaros and mustangs that are as guilty
of that as some of those hondas
you know that have like that hide that
that [ __ ] whatever the hell that is
somebody sipping out of a straw
sound as they go down the [ __ ]
with your sideways muffler
um
oh god i love being old bitching about
stupid [ __ ] like this
um
my daughter already went back to school
i was so [ __ ] bummed out
there's just nothing better than your
kid on summer vacation
if you're a stand-up comedian and your
kids on summer vacation like it's like
it's like you guys you're in the same
universe it's like you don't have to
[ __ ] to do all day either do you
let's hang out
let's have some [ __ ] grilled cheese
sandwiches let's make some waffles
i cannot wait
for her first vacation
i'm going to start lining up my
vacations
with her vacation when she's on i'm on
when she's off i'm off that's all that's
how i'm going to work it
i'm not doing stand-up weekends anymore
i'm do i'm working during the week okay
hey i'm doing a different way all right
i don't know what to tell you
um red sox are doing all right working
their way through the bottom feeders of
the league
how we doing here oh we got oh jesus not
too well tonight
this [ __ ] kid man he's already out of
breath it's the second inning he said
nothing but base runners it's still zero
to zero we're playing the twins we won
the first game last night
we won two out of three of the rangers
one of them got postponed
there we go fielder's choice fielder's
choice
i love it there's one out runner's at
the corners
okay
double play is still existing let's get
a ground ball to short jesus christ
who's that guy or gordon
on the twins can somebody give that dude
a sandwich
my god
i don't think that guy weighs 130 pounds
can you stop body shaming african
americans on the minnesota twins
when is it gonna stop
um it's roman everybody you know most
guys have different ways to last longer
but thinking about baseball doesn't
always work the folks at roman and
online's men health company are changing
the game with roman swipes the secret to
longer lasting sex
roman swipes are clinically proven a
clinically proven way to last longer in
bed there's effective easy use and fast
acting but don't require prescription
roman can ship swipes to you in a
discrete unmarked packaging and each
swipe packet is small enough to hide in
your wallet for whenever you need it
swipes are great
uh they will not transfer to your
partner so they uh so you can last
longer without worrying jesus christ
they need glasses
they're super easy to use just take the
swipes out of the packet swipe it on let
it dry and you're good to go that's it
bang away go get roman go to
getroman.com
and get ten dollars off your first order
of swipes plus free two dollars two day
shipping
that's get roman.com
for ten dollars off your first order of
swipes plus free two-day shipping oh
look who it is it's liquid death
everyone you know you're already no
liquid death you see the tall boy cans
of fresh spring water at whole foods at
punk concerts at your brother's friend's
bachelor party
you go hard on these cans of liquid
death chug them down like you mean it
but did you know you can now rock their
hardcore merch
while quenching your thirst and saving
the environment that's right no more
plastic bottles time for a drinking game
hey pass me that liquid death let's go
i'll be the designated driver give me
that ice cold aluminum can with the
skull i drink this [ __ ] all the time
people it's delicious um this water is
giving me life why do they call liquid
death liquid death also donates 10 of
the profits to help kill plastic
pollution forever and by the way when
you drink out of a plastic bottle some
of the chemicals of plastic are in the
water it's a much healthier option and
you know what is anything better than a
nice cold aluminum can as opposed to
some plastic bottle come on use your
brain here all right try to think of
something more hardcore than that
spoiler you can't murder your thirst
and kill plastic pollution save the
earth look dope as hell with liquid
death it takes up to 1000 years for
plastic bottles to decompose
your plastic will outlive you times 10
even if you make it you know to 100.
simple math bill it's a win-win-win
situation you'll see these cans popping
up everywhere liquid death is available
at your local whole foods or 7-eleven go
to liquiddeth.com
b-u-r-r to get free shipping on all the
water and merch that's
liquiddeth.com get free shipping on all
the water in merch grab some now at
whole foods or 7-eleven
now and totally murder your thirst come
on man it's the right thing to do all
right it's helix everybody helix getting
good night's sleep is everything it
affects your mental and physical health
as much as anything helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes two
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made from
someone else with helix
uh you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
so if you're looking for a mattress you
can take the quiz you order the mattress
that your helix
you order the mattress that your helix
what so if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that your helix is awesome but you don't
need to take my word for it well there's
something missing in that sentence helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress picks of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine helix has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep just
go to helixleep.com
take their two-minute quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life and nothing keeps you healthy and
not catching colds and all of that [ __ ]
like a good night's sleep they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nice risk free
they'll even pick it up for you gross if
you don't love it but you will helix
even has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never that far away helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 dollars
off all mattresses orders and two free
pillows all right lastly but not look
leastly
can't talk today my bookie how the [ __ ]
you doing huh
uh winning s zn returns at my bookie.ag
and it's time to get an in on the action
i don't think i was supposed to say sen
winning returns at my bookie and it's
note and it's time ah [ __ ] me let's
start my bookie everybody winning
returns at my bookie and it's time to
get in on all the action there we go
first time players can get started by
doubling your first deposit giving you
the firepower to add excitement to the
games you love college football odds
boost nfl lock of the week and over 500
000 in contest prizes
uh live on sites to make this winning
season your best ever with my bookie
uh with the historic 18-week schedule
offering more action than ever before
you need a sports book casino that's
reliable and you won't find a better
place to go than my bookie how to [ __ ]
you doing
uh i know you're going to uh i know
you're going to bet this season so do
the smart things sign up with my bookie
and use our promo code burr burr to get
the first ever deposit match dollar for
dollar
that's extra money credited to your
account instantly just for using the
promo code bur bur-r making your first
deposit uh mybookie.com promo code burp
b-u-r-r bet anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie
is this even a podcast anymore is this i
don't even know what the hell i talked
about you know it's funny i said as i as
i hit record i was thinking to myself i
don't have anything to talk about
what in god's name
am i going to talk about next thing you
know
see you know i'm talking about rednecks
selling shotguns on [ __ ] late night
tv
you know what band i i always bring up
killing joke right death and
resurrection show and i knew that they
had been around
in the the
80s
i finally went back and i started
listening to music what a [ __ ] great
band
there was so much great music in the 80s
that i missed it's really
it's really ridiculous
um
killing joke that song uh living in the
80s literally making fun of the 80s as
they were happening as they were
happening
you know
that's pretty [ __ ] impressive
as far as the way that they show the 80s
like everybody had big hair and was
doing blow
you know and just having a great [ __ ]
time
you know it's really weird how they do
that and then they make the 90s like
every all the white kids were all sad
and depressed
and it had no direction
reality bites remember all that [ __ ]
phelan minnesota
i'm feeling minnesota
i like that line let's call the movie
that i never even seen that movie but
remember they kept
all that grunge [ __ ]
you guys know i never i never [ __ ] i
never related to that
it was funny was i was in a walking
depression throughout all of the 90s and
i remember looking at people like what
are they so upset about
you know
did you just put on dr feelgood you feel
not the aretha franklin version
the vince neil
motley crew version
that's what i was listening i listened
to that [ __ ] maybe that's why i didn't i
didn't get into grunge
you know
i didn't get into grunge the same reason
why i didn't try mushrooms forever it's
just i knew it wasn't going to go well
it's like i don't need i i need people
that are happier than me
so i need people to lift me up i don't
want people to be like yeah
you think that's bad
i'm shooting heroin under a bridge ah
jesus christ just when i thought the day
couldn't get any more rainier and gray
you know
that's why i just stuck with that other
[ __ ]
in the basement
not the old manta
talk dirty to me
i mean just
there was no thinking involved
huey lewis
i'll tell you you know who ruined all of
that music was that american psycho
music
music i mean that movie
that made everybody seem like they were
some [ __ ]
you know
guy going through the motions he was
actually killing people i know bill we
saw the [ __ ] movie
um
i listen all that [ __ ] working in a
[ __ ] warehouse
phil collins was on every third song was
a phil collins song if it wasn't a phil
collins song it was a genesis song
you know and then there was one
there was one summer where all he did
was play that band the outfield i
remember that in the warehouse
that guy with that ridiculously high
voice
[Music]
[ __ ] playing softballs on the
softball team for the warehouse drinking
wine coolers
full head of flaming red hair
what was stopping me everything
um
anyway i know at some point i'm going to
get some advertising that i have to read
here um
so anyway uh
yeah my kid went back to school i lost
my buddy for the day
sucks
wow this is what it's gonna feel like
someday when she [ __ ] moves out
you know i got you know guys my age
they've already passed that [ __ ] they
get like [ __ ] grandkids my i started
so goddamn late but they all talk about
that the day that kid moves out
i think that's that's when you know you
have a douche for a kid
or you just suck as a parent
if you're counting down the days your
kid turns 18.
i got 18 more months and that
[ __ ]
i mean how many strings are is it okay
if i go live at school absolutely junior
get the [ __ ] out of here
that would be pretty well but what if
you just had a douche for a kid because
some people you know let me just see if
being a douche
is like
is that something you become or can you
just be born a douche
all right let's look this up i know this
is a stupid question
is being a douche
genetic oh my god i can actually [ __ ]
it says being a jerk genetic
being a jerk
could be in your genes you got to be
[ __ ] kidding me
this article's 10 years old how did i
find this
what's hilarious is they have a picture
of an old woman
you know
shaking her fist like whoa why are you
going to go after the old ladies here
oh god they have more [ __ ] ads
popping up here i don't want to buy
anything
my wallet is in the house
i'm in the [ __ ] garage here
all right according to a u.s study
a new u.s study people with a certain
gene trait are known
uh are known be kinder than people
without it all right right there this is
[ __ ]
nationalpost.com right you can't even
get the first sentence right without us
according without a typo according to a
new u.s study people with a certain gene
trait are known
be kinder than people without it and
strangers can quickly tell the
difference
we were interested if our genes can
predict what complete strangers think of
us from as little as 20 seconds
from seeing us
am i going insane are there words
missing from these sentences
oh said alexander
a-l-e-k-s-a-n-d-r okay this is second
language all right hang on a second
lead writer of the study and post on a
postdoctoral
fellow at the university of toronto
in the last 10 years there has been this
emerging work that suggests that
oxytocin a chemical messenger in our
brain
is involved
making us kind to one another making us
empathetic making us more trustworthy
oxytocin toxin is something called the
love hormone because it's often
manifests during sex and promotes
bonding empathy and other pro-social
behaviors
oh god everything from cooking sites
where they have recipes to like
literally this [ __ ] can you just get to
what the [ __ ] i asked
okay scientists in oregon state one
member tells us in most cases the
observers were able to tell which of the
listeners had the kindness gene and
which ones did not
this is not what i asked
people who have gigi are generally
judged as more empathetic
okay
a non-verbal trust those with a g or a a
gene types tend to say they feel less
positive overall
however kogan said our gene trait
doesn't necessarily determine how kind
you are stressing more research needs to
be done yeah
yeah what a bunch of [ __ ] that was
what a [ __ ] waste of time
see if there's anything else like
the [ __ ] gene
[ __ ] as the brits say
oh [ __ ] or as the brisk say
arseholes
um
the philosopher aaron i don't give a
[ __ ]
you know what
one of the worst things about learning
is it involves reading
i think that's why i'm going to remain
dumb for the rest of my life i just i
just don't have the [ __ ] stamina
get to the [ __ ] point can they you
know
i swear to god did they get paid by the
word is that what the [ __ ] it is
bill don't blame your laziness your add
and whatever else you got going on on
people writing articles on the internet
all right fair enough all right people
that's a podcast
um i hope you enjoyed this i was just
checking in on you
let me i want to hear from the gun
people out there they have gun people
out there
baby
i want to hear from the nugent fans out
there i want to know if i got a [ __ ]
paint gun
all right and i feel like i got to be
less accurate
you aren't those paintballs like as big
as like a [ __ ] uh
no kumquat
aren't those things as big as a tumor
and a tumor the size of a kumquat
um
yeah i just got to just [ __ ] blam
blam blah blah blam right
and all you guys who go down to the
[ __ ] yeah you know
shooting those those car those paper
cutouts of people
i love how they're always people you
know what i mean
he always has the same [ __ ] haircut
do you think they traced a certain
person to make that
that would be crazy imagine if you were
actually like you know uh what's his
face is the logo for the nba
what if that's that that's you're like
the [ __ ]
practice shooting a person in the head
paper [ __ ] logo you're the silhouette
of that
and one day you walk down the street to
some [ __ ] gun nut he just sees it and
just out of instinct
you know he goes for his [ __ ] ankle
gun
unloads a clip in your [ __ ] head
and as you're floating above your body
watching you take your last breaths you
like i knew would come to that
the saddest thing was i got no residuals
it was a buyout
gun people
i know you go to the the the range
you know what i mean
i knew you probably killed your first
wife and buried her under a [ __ ] well
that you dug yourself and put a potted
plant on the top of it
just waiting for that day somebody comes
in you know you're behind in the
payments of your house can't sell the
house man you got a body on that
property
there was just a way to move that body
right before we close
but how will i get the smell up i gotta
need to rent a pickup
um
so you guys who go to the [ __ ] gun
range
all right and all you guys are great
with your guns and everything okay two
questions have you ever been shot at
while trying to
hit a target
all right
i just eliminated 90 of gun owners now
i'm just talking to veterans and not all
veterans veterans who saw action i wanna
i want a veteran that saw action
that hit targets while being shot at or
a cop
i wanna i want you guys to to give me
your honest opinion on my paint gun
theory
all right
because if my ears ring any louder i
don't want to [ __ ] be here anyway so
i don't care if the person shoots me so
i need to have a [ __ ]
i need i need a
a paint gun because it's quiet click
click click click
the only thing i'll hear is the
screaming of the person
um
because that is the thing that i don't
understand
about owning a [ __ ] gun
um
like the great let's let's say something
positive about florida the great thing
is silencers are legal
so
if you have a gun by the side of of your
uh
your nightstand there and you have a
silencer on it
already
so then when somebody's coming up the
stairs
you're just like this is great
this is perfect
i don't have to put in earplugs i have
to worry about doing permanent damage to
my hearing
i'm not going to wake up my neighbors
hell i probably want to wake up half my
kids down the hall
and you can just sit there you know like
you're picking the remote up to change
the channel on the tv and you just click
click click over
um
i wonder if i could get a waiver
i'm getting this gun for home protection
but i have like
ringing in my ears could i get a
silencer
but it's like really bad
all right i'm just babbling okay
everybody enjoy your weekend go red sox
nfl football
college football
the second half of uh
motogp and f1 is happening right right
now
tennis us open
that's got to be going on right now or
coming up or something
um
and old freckles is going to florida
i'm going down there
i'll take that oxy i'll take that meth
you keep that vaccination away from me
[ __ ]
my body my choice
i'm gonna have fun with those [ __ ]
i'm really looking forward to getting
down there
uh that is it that is all go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend and i'll
talk to you later enjoy the music and
the bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
august 26th
2013. what do you say there fuckos
how are you how's it going holy [ __ ]
where did the summer go
you know i always make fun of that i
always make fun of people who go oh my
god can you believe it's already august
um i worked my ass off this summer so
the summer did fly by i can't believe it
i didn't get the layout or anything
i didn't get to tan myself up
i didn't get to red myself up at all you
know did you guys lay out there get a
little skin cancer
um i am finally
i'm finally back in uh los angeles
after spending a month in new orleans i
had a great [ __ ] time down there
ended it with on a great note
you know i settled my differences with
the city i finally said you know what
you win
i'm gonna have some of your fried
[ __ ] food
and um i ended up going i went bow
fishing
out in the bayou
a [ __ ] bow and arrow right i got
myself a six pack of bud talls
this is america a few people overseas
right now
for you people over there i don't know
what we did to you i don't know what
we're doing to you right now what we're
gonna do to you in the future that's to
make you [ __ ] passively aggressive
aggressively attack the great game of
american football
you know because you won't get to the
real core of the issue that you don't
like our foreign policy
and by r i mean me because i sit in on
those meetings
i'm making the calls
you know
and all you [ __ ] [ __ ] over there who
every week every week i'm getting these
[ __ ] emails of people still [ __ ] and
acting like nfl football players aren't
tough compared to rugby because they
wear helmets do you realize how [ __ ]
dumb that is
that's like saying well you know so
basically if you're in a car you can
drive it into a tree and you won't get
hurt because you're in a car is that
what you're telling me
huh with all your poorly [ __ ] white
guys waddling around out there putting
shoulders into chest
okay
that's not what we're talking about here
we're not talking about a bunch of pasty
[ __ ] white dudes running around who
can't even run a [ __ ]
5 second 40.
that's not what we're talking about at
all
all right
we're talking about a game
that is played at a size and speed that
is not seen
overseas it just isn't you know why
because you're not big enough you're not
fast enough and you know why that is
because you never went to a country that
was bigger and stronger and forced them
to come over here and do all the hard
[ __ ]
see
what you guys did was you [ __ ] went
to where they lived and you tried to
[ __ ] build a castle over there stupid
stupid [ __ ] movie what happened you
lost all of it
so what do you do now do you own up to
it
and just say you know what america is
better at pressing the world right now
than we are now
you don't man up and say that you send
me [ __ ] [ __ ] emails about a goddamn
game
i've told you from the very beginning
rugby players are the toughest sons of
[ __ ] you know they're tough you know
great [ __ ] game i really enjoy it
okay
well let's not pretend that if leon let
right now rolled up the [ __ ] couch
and decided to run down the [ __ ]
pitch in some short shorts
that you know those guys wouldn't be
falling over on their backs they would
i'm sorry
it's bigger it's stronger
it's faster
hence you know and then you put a helmet
on now you got a weapon that's all it is
it protects your skull but your [ __ ]
brains going but
inside that [ __ ] thing and next thing
you know you're on the roof of your
house when you're 40 years old shooting
at mall cops that's what happens to our
retired players what do you guys do
huh
[ __ ] uh get your ears fixed
finally get that wedgie taken out of
your ass i don't know what you do
when you retire
as a rugby player i'm sorry people i'm a
little grumpy right now
all right um
i finished my uh my acting gig
my big song and dance number down there
i'd like to thank mike binder for giving
me a shot on that thing
um
and the second i was done
i ended up going up to uh boston before
i came home because i had a gig
at the uh the mgm
mgm casino there in connecticut
not in las vegas i played the one at
connecticut which is like going to the
university of miami ohio
[Music]
no i'm kidding it was a great gig and i
want to thank everybody who showed up
and everything and i was in a [ __ ]
grumpy mood
when i came out on that one
i started [ __ ] on paul version i was
going off on the traffic i just i just
i just really needed to go home and have
a fudgical
you know some comforts i don't know what
the [ __ ] i needed i'm still all wound up
ah [ __ ] where the hell did this [ __ ]
year go
i gotta tell you this i lost my [ __ ]
i know i started to tell someone oh bow
fishing i'll get back to that
remind me remind me to get back to the
bow fishing thing
um
i forgot what the [ __ ] i was just going
to talk about the oh the traffic
my [ __ ] brain moves in a straight
line a very slow but it [ __ ] line but
it is a straight line
if i miss the exit it just keeps going
and i can't i can't turn around
um
see it made me [ __ ] forget the
traffic
i lost my [ __ ] like three [ __ ] times
when i was up in boston
all right
i [ __ ] hate that city now
i love it i love the sports teams but i
hate that [ __ ] city because you land
in it and the first thing you go you
drive into is that big dig which is the
biggest [ __ ] scam
i i ever perpetrated when it comes to
[ __ ] transportation jesus talked my
way out of that one didn't i i didn't
know where to go with that how the [ __ ]
do you [ __ ] on a highway
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they just took everything they put it
underground they made it all one lane
everything's [ __ ] one lane
i don't know if they're anticipating
some
some plague or something i don't know
what but that thing like this should
just be like model t's oh god driving
around that [ __ ] thing they didn't
add any lanes
every time i go in there the whole
[ __ ] thing shut down they got the ted
williams tunnel you know what they
should have outside the head ted ted
williams tunnel they should have his
head upside down on a tuna can
you know like made out of concrete and
tribute to and said and then tell his
family that we're gonna [ __ ] leave
that up there until you give that man
the proper burial that he [ __ ]
deserves
so anyways you're going to [ __ ] teddy
ball game tunnel
and there is enough room for like five
[ __ ] lanes and there's only two and
then there's this this i don't know what
this bike lane
for the obese
what is the [ __ ] it's never open and
then the other one always has cones on
it
sorry i've gone there like three times
this [ __ ] year and no matter what
time i drive in there there's [ __ ]
traffic because of that [ __ ]
oh i'm in a mood i am going to move
people i admit it
and here's another thing i'm driving
down to my gig going down to the [ __ ]
mgm thing there
mgm miami ohio gig that i had and i'm
it's [ __ ] 2 30 on a friday afternoon
should be wide open bumper-to-bumper
[ __ ] traffic
you know
bumper-to-bumper [ __ ] traffic i don't
i i got to the point i literally wanted
to roll down the window and just and ask
the guy next to me where the [ __ ] are
you going
don't you have a job are you also a
comedian
you know are you uh do you work the
[ __ ] night shift please tell me
you're actually driving to your job and
you're not just out here to be out here
i [ __ ] come back from the mgm thing i
get myself four [ __ ] hours to get up
to logan airport
no three hours to get up to [ __ ]
logan airport so i'd have a two-hour
[ __ ] window
to get to my goddamn plane and i and i
end up getting a bumper-to-bumper
traffic the second i get near the south
shore pleasure bumper to [ __ ] bumper
traffic like 12 30 in the afternoon on a
saturday
you know what where where the [ __ ]
those [ __ ] idiots sat in traffic
monday through friday did are they
do they like sitting in traffic
it actually made me look up the
population i was like here's is the
population
exploding in this country because i
didn't think it was we were doing that
bad
i started doing the road hardcore around
97.98 we had about 267 million people
we'll just say 268 okay
before i get some [ __ ] email from
somebody works from the census
and now we're up to
313.9 so we'll call that 314.
all right so what's that
no jesus he's going to do some math here
that's 32 million plus 14 million that's
46 million people
spread out over 50 states i don't
[ __ ] know if that's the problem or
what but i'll tell you they're all out
on the highway
it's almost worth being president
you know
just so you don't have to sit in [ __ ]
traffic it's almost worth just becoming
an absolute yes man and signing off on
[ __ ] like spying on american people
being able to put american citizens in
jail indefinitely without a [ __ ]
trial just because you think they're a
[ __ ] terrorist it's almost worth
doing that
you know
just so you don't have to sit in the
traffic
maybe i'll just get like a helicopter
license i'll get one of those little
two-seater ones you know
basically the smart car of uh
air travel
there's a lot of flat [ __ ] things out
there that you can land on
structures
and what are people gonna do if you land
on their roof
and just rappel down what are they gonna
call a tow truck
hey you can't leave it there yeah i just
did i'll be back in 20 minutes
you don't even know who the [ __ ] the
call about this
what are you gonna call cops you gotta
stand here with your hands on your hip
that is a helicopter
you know
well [ __ ] keep it i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll get another one
all right cost me 400 bucks look at it
um
sorry this is just all this is what
being away from your [ __ ]
for uh a month does to you and then you
come home and you have a mountain of
junk mail
you know i realize in my mail nobody
sends me anything nice
i don't get one [ __ ]
hey just thinking about you i guess
that's emails now
you know back in the day when somebody
would just you know
because you couldn't call him
he had to have some [ __ ] jerk off
right a pony
with your goddamn i didn't write a pony
he rode a horse why did they call it the
pony express
i would tell you guys when i was a kid i
thought a pony was a little horse
and eventually it grew into a horse
so he's [ __ ] people down the street
at a pony and it was ridiculous they had
it tied up to the back of their house i
don't think they had a fence
[ __ ] or maybe they had a little bit
of a fence this thing just stood there
we're driving by the thing for years and
i finally looked over at my mother i'm
just like
i'm like when the when is that pony
going to turn into a horse
she just sort of looked at me you know
i didn't realize that look when i was a
kid but i realize it now
where she just was like
she was literally looking at me like
who did i mate with
that that that came out of me and just
asked me that
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
anyways
so i want to thank everybody who came
out to uh
the mgm in uh
connecticut wherever the hell i was it's
[ __ ] beautiful out there
that's the one thing i do like and the
one thing i really do miss about living
out here in la
is uh i miss all those trees and the
lakes
i love that [ __ ]
you know maybe one of those douche bags
that [ __ ] sells this house here in
the city and just goes out and gets a
ranch
can't even [ __ ] change a light bulb
buy the whole outfit you know
big stupid cowboy hat and some chaps
getting in and out in and out of my
prius
you know no i could drive my old truck
that's what i do and before i went in
town to get provisions i just roll
around in the dirt to make it look like
i was actually out doing something
oh christ um
anyways
oh you know what let's let's bang out
let's bang out a little [ __ ] uh
should we no no no you know what i
started talking about the bow fishing
let's let's finish it so my last night
there
i get invited out to go bow fishing
and uh
i was just like yeah i'll [ __ ] do
that
shoot fish with the bow and arrow
i i don't know how to do that but i
would like to know how to do it
why not right
so
we [ __ ] go out there
it's like a group of uh
four
and we meet these guys at a gas station
you got to get a fishing license and all
this [ __ ]
and uh you know i got a six-pack of
budweiser i mean you're getting on a
boat i mean you have to where i'm from
you have to do that if you're getting on
a boat you have to have a six-pack of
something and you got to drink it or
else you're an [ __ ]
so i got it and one of the guys is like
dude you're gonna have a weapon
it's like yeah well i'm not gonna be
pointing it at you or me
pointing at the fish let's try to make
this a little sporting here
you know
it's not like i'm taking a stick like
tom hanks in that [ __ ] movie where he
talked to the soccer ball cast away well
said right
dude we went out on this fan boat
yeah
all the way out in the [ __ ] bayou it
was terrifying
it was [ __ ] the second we got out
there was because we did it at night
it was a full moon it was a [ __ ] you
know i kept thinking of you know that
movie southern comfort with powers booth
that's what i thought about and i felt
good that i was thinking about that not
deliverance because i feel like that's
hacky at this point
you know
one fat pasty dude gets banged in the
ass in the woods and nobody can remember
southern comfort after that it's [ __ ]
ridiculous i think it's high time that
stops
all right so anyways
um
it was it was it was amazing
basically when you bow fish
i don't know i don't know what to even
begin this [ __ ] the guy had like a
flashlight
one of these born in the bayou guys and
he go right there right there right
there right there
bow and arrows
trying to shoot some fish that was just
[ __ ] chilling out
and uh
basically what you do is is you shoot
wherever you wherever the fish looks
like it is you shoot like five inches
below it because it's an illusion man
because of the
water so it took a little bit of time to
get to get used to that so what i did
was i started aiming at all these small
fish
just bringing the bow up because i
realized i was just shooting i wasn't
aiming
i was just kind of shooting in the
general direction i kept missing so i
was practicing on the little fish i
didn't shoot at him i would just bring
it up just to get the muscle memory
and i did all right i hit i hit three
in about um
three hours averaged like one an hour
there was a lot of looking for him i'm
not gonna lie to you so i wasn't that
bad but i missed a lot
um
but i got three including one
we [ __ ] pulled this thing in
and it was uh
had an alligator face and the back
looked like an eel it's called an
alligator gar
the thing looked beyond evil looked like
a [ __ ] dinosaur
and we got in the boat they're like all
right watch out watch your feet don't
let it bite you don't let it bite you
and all that [ __ ] and everybody's like
dude you gotta get a picture with that
you got blood on your face it looks
[ __ ] awesome everybody's saying all
this [ __ ] you know i gotta tell you you
tap into that inner [ __ ] caveman
because when i went out there i
immediately had this sinking feeling
like i can't go back to [ __ ]
the village
without bringing home something to eat
that's still in me
and the village was my [ __ ] hotel
room where i have room service it was
[ __ ] stupid but i literally felt that
i don't want to be the guy that doesn't
[ __ ] get something
so anyways so now i'm feeling like a
[ __ ] man because i killed this
goddamn thing
and uh
i don't know so i'm like all right so
what do we do here you know we killed a
bunch of fish and i asked the guy go can
you you guys are gonna you know clean
these things you put the [ __ ] meat on
ice or some [ __ ] and ship it to me
and the guy's just like
yeah no
no
[Laughter]
so then i was like well what the [ __ ]
we're just out here killing [ __ ]
and it just kind of bugged me oh no
what's going on here how come i'm not
getting any readings here
i think it's recording what the [ __ ] is
going on with my mixer
oh is it just saying it's really loud
what is this what is this come on come
on talk to me talk to me
what's wrong with my mixer
ah jesus christ now i gotta i gotta shut
this off i'm going to splice this
together you're not going to notice but
i got to make sure i'm recording here
hang on
all right so it was recording i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on with the
mixer what did i do what did i do to it
oh gives a [ __ ] so anyways i uh
so at that point i was like all right
well i killed three of these things
the other two that i shot they were
[ __ ] beautiful really thick
and i was like you know if i'm going to
kill these things i want to [ __ ] eat
it i just want to be putting holes in
[ __ ]
but anyways i guess that alligator gar
thing can survive
out of the water for a couple hours so
we were able to put that one back or
they they said they were going to so i
don't know that's the only part i didn't
like other than that it was [ __ ]
great
and uh
yeah it felt like it was in like a mad
max movie thoroughly enjoy it just next
time i do it i only want to kill like
one
you know or kill like two or three and
then [ __ ]
clean them take it and [ __ ] eat it
for the week
does that make sense i think i made me
feel bad was i went home and i looked up
the alligator gar and i was looking
waiting for it to be oh the most vicious
[ __ ]
alligator eel
this side of the [ __ ] mississippi
yeah and they didn't they were just like
yeah it's kind of it's very docile
if it sees you it's shy and swims away
you know it's like oh man
i shot a [ __ ]
nerd an ugly nerd fish with an arrow and
i judged it because of its face
like it was evil you know
i don't know
the people i went with they also hunt uh
wild pigs that's that's something else i
could shoot i could shoot a [ __ ] pig
dear i couldn't do that who's kidding
who if i was starving i could do it
you know
i shoot a [ __ ] cat if i was hungry
hungry enough
does anything i learned from reading
that [ __ ] book fly boys
and no that's not about a boy band
you know what's up brooklyn we are fly
boys
um
sorry i saw the vmas run tonight
what's the deal with vmas
i know a lot of people say this but
doesn't mtv have a lot of [ __ ] balls
they don't show videos but they still
have their video music awards
you know i know that's completely hacky
but like
i actually saw some of the videos i'm
like these are [ __ ] great videos i
wish they would show them where can i
see these how do i know this music is
out where do i go now
can anybody help me
well can you
um all right let's do a little bit of
advertising here for this week everybody
all right dollar shave club everybody
dolla
there are so many things in the world
that irritate me traffic at 2 30 in the
afternoon on a saturday or a friday
you know
stewardesses who just love talking on
that microphone
we want to thank you for flying american
airlines our flying time today is three
hours 22 minutes and 18 seconds
there's going to be a time difference
shut up lady sit out
um
when so many things can irritate you why
add razors to the list that doesn't make
any sense does it it's time to stop
milking your razor blade everybody
i know with brand name razors you're
used to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those razors until they start
to look like rusty soda cans and start
carving up your face there it's time to
move on move on to a better world dollar
shave club delivers amazing quality
blades to your door for just a few bucks
a month everybody never think about it
again they send a pack
they send a pack every so you can change
your blades every week that's not me
that's missing a thing
they send you a pack every month i guess
is what it's supposed to be so you can
change your blades every week i love
these guys and your face will love them
too
um they also got a brand new product
called one white charlie's
[Laughter]
you know if that line was in the movie
platoon that would probably be really
offensive
way one wipe charlie um it's a butt wipe
for men
what and it's classy
check out the video for that there's no
way there's no way that's true
there's no way that's true
they got a new but i hope it's true one
one wipe charlie's it's a butt wipe for
men but what about women they supposed
to walk around with a stinky ass or you
trying to say that they wipe their asses
better
oh my god the sky is falling anyways i
guess they're classy check out the video
for that if you're into scat and sign up
for your razors today go to dollar shave
club forward slash burr that's dollar
shave club forward slash bar or go to
billboard.com and click on the dollar
shave club banner
i really hope one type one one white
charlie's was a joke because that's
hilarious
you mean baby wipes the baby wipes the
poor man's bidet
um hulu plus everyone i'm sure you've
tried hulu.com but i want to tell you
about hulu plus
hence the title hulu plus hulu plus lets
you watch thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere streaming on your tv
or on the go with your smartphone or
tablet why stand in line or ride a train
and just stare at your feet why would
you want to do that when you can be
watching your favorite shows on hulu
plus hulu plus is a great way to binge
watch your favorite shows hulu plus has
tons of episodes from great comedies
like snl community modern family south
park family guy and thousands of other
shows
hey how much is it a month 7.99 that's
7.99 7.99
okay before you think it's really
expensive
all right for all the shows and movies
you can watch catch up on current shows
binge watch on old favorites or catch a
great movie you can do it all on hulu
plus right now you can try hulu plus for
a couple of weeks
free on me when you go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com bill all right please make
sure you you use hulupus.com bill so you
can get an extended free trial extending
it
stretching the defense throwing the long
ball on first down here so they know
that we sent you all right there you go
huluplus.com
one more here e-voice
okay if you're an entrepreneur
and a customer calls do you want to seem
like you're in a high-rise
window view fancy-pants office of course
you do
wouldn't you want to do that or do you
want to
oh wait or do you want them to know
you're sitting in your underwear
like me right now doing this podcast you
don't want that you want to come off
like a pro
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building sales
customer support tech support you name
it sounds like you got the whole damn
thing give your customers the royal
treatment with e-voice e-voice will
forward business calls to your home
mobile or any number you choose wherever
you are e-voice will find you it's kind
of creepy don't have time to take a call
it's routed to a voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as an email
e-voice not only gives you an edge over
your competition it takes away the edge
the big companies have over you right
now because you can pretend to be just
as big as they are
and now you can try evoice for free for
30 days go to evoice.com and use the
promo code bill b-i-l-l that's e-voice
promo code bill or just go to the
podcast page at billbird.com and click
on that e-voice banner god damn you
all right
back to the podcast
yeah so there you go you can add that to
my list of skills
all right i can bow fish hunt
provided somebody shows up with the bow
and the arrow and has the boat
that's not bad right that's a good skill
to have
when the dollar collapses and i'm out
here in the desert with no lakes
[Laughter]
well i can modify it then
you know what the [ __ ] could i shoot
what can you shoot that's not a fish but
it's like a fish and it's out of the
water i know a toddler there you go
and you know what i wouldn't be killing
more than i was going to eat i'd only
take one
bill why are you talking about
cannibalism because i just read an
amazing book called fly boys
um jesus christ what a book what a
[ __ ] book that was
it's unreal everybody has done horrific
things
around the planet like right now how
we're sitting there giving uh
the powers that be [ __ ] over there in
syria
damascus whatever the [ __ ] it is for
possibly using chemical weapons
i don't know
some of the [ __ ] we've done we got a lot
of [ __ ] nerve
is this thing recording
what is with my goddamn electronics this
week i don't know you know what bill
stop blaming the technology why don't
you man up
um yeah you got to read this book it's
really just balanced and it just shows
the [ __ ] horrific [ __ ]
that
basically the uh the the americans did
and the japanese did to each other
and then also the unbelievable
heroic stuff that they did it's the
whole goddamn thing
every color of the rainbow
um i don't know how to talk about it
without [ __ ] ruining the book
um
i don't know it just uh i can tell you
one [ __ ] story's kind who
douchebags aren't going to read it if
you listen to this podcast there's no
way you read
i'll tell you one quick story all right
this will probably take two minutes if
you want to [ __ ] fast forward
they're going in to bomb this goddamn
island shaped like a horseshoe right
and the thing is is what they're bombing
all right he's right in the uh like you
know you know what a horseshoe looks
like right
sure we all do we all have a [ __ ]
crazy uncle that has a horse don't you
or a pony
all right the bottom of the horseshoe
not the two ends where the luck runs out
if you
hang it upside down right there like
you're going around the going around the
corner right right down there what part
of the horseshoe was that called you
know what's funny people who do
crossword puzzles know what that part of
the horseshoe is called
anyways that part down there like if
you're pouring water into it where would
gather we got it bill that's where the
[ __ ] radio station was and they had
to basically fly right into it
all right but on the sides
that's where the mountains were they
were actually above where the airplanes
were the mountains on the sides were so
high up and these guys had to come in so
low that the anti-aircraft
fire was coming down on them
these guys had to have the [ __ ] balls
20 years old 19 20 years old to fly in
there and just be like well they're not
going to get me the other guy's got to
get it and
knowing full well
that if they got caught they were gonna
get [ __ ] tortured and just they
basically told them to keep one in the
chamber
and just [ __ ] blow your brains out
because when if these guys catch you
after the [ __ ] you've done
um you know because
once once once airplanes
got involved uh i guess way more
civilians started to get killed
and i know that sounds obvious but like
i never really thought about that
i thought back in the day like the
revolutionary wars i mean i thought
people just you know just
indiscriminately raped and pillaged and
went all the way around i guess you
could
but uh you had to be a man about it you
know
you had to kick open the door you know
kill a couple of males
and then tackle somebody in a house coat
you know all kinds of scratches to your
face i mean yeah you [ __ ] got you got
dirty
you got dirty back in the day then all
of a sudden the advent of the air aerial
aerial type plane there right does this
sound as dumb as it sounds to me out
loud they [ __ ]
you could just fly over you know
you're trying to hit a warehouse you're
in a house you blow up a couple of
babies and some people they [ __ ]
hated these pilots
they thought they were coward that they
thought they were devils
and uh
so they didn't want to get caught or
whatever so this [ __ ] guy is flying
in
anti-aircraft fire comes in the flack
that's what they call it flack that's
what i call my boss would give me [ __ ]
for not unloading a truck quick enough
that's what i called flack at 20 years
of age these guys had such big balls
that's what they called people
trying to shoot down the [ __ ]
airplane they were in
so it's basically
like softball-sized holes are going
through this guy's [ __ ]
wings
and he loses it he goes into his spin so
he tells the two guys in the back that
they got to bail out
so he's got to do this move
where he brings up like the the [ __ ]
flap on the right wing and then
something with the rudder he go it
basically causes the plane to kind of go
sideways and it gives these guys a
chance to open the door in the back
because if they couldn't the air
pressure would like hold it tight so the
guy's doing this move as the front of
his plane is on fire and the flames are
lapping at his feet he's doing this
maneuver so his buddies can get out
and it works both his buddies jump out
and now the [ __ ] plane it's almost
going to hit the goddamn water it's in a
flat spin this guy takes off his
seatbelt he's still fighting it you take
the seat belt off that's the last thing
you're getting out and at the last
second he catches it
and he comes out of the spin
and goes up
and then he looks back seeing his two
buddies
[ __ ] landing in the water and they're
gonna swim and get taken prisoner by the
japanese and the guy was completely
you couldn't be unconsolable
landed on the aircraft carrier it was
just
bawling
just all he could say over and over
again was i took my seat belt off
meaning i was gonna bail out it was just
you know
it's just [ __ ] i i butchered that
story just imagine someone who can
actually write
telling you that story it's a [ __ ]
unbelievable book
it'll make you a better person when you
read it
and um
jesus christ
i i i think i'm going to read a whole
bunch of books on the world war two now
in in
and and like the uh the part of the war
i want to say specifically the pacific
ocean i just don't feel those words go
go together if well
particularly the pacific ocean part of
it because i all that [ __ ] okinawa iwo
jima i don't know where that [ __ ] was
they had a map and everything
you know dummy like me actually was it
was really
if it's gonna be a book like that where
they they show the dirt on both sides
that's the kind of [ __ ] that i like
just fire bombing cities
this is [ __ ] unreal
you know
you basically on both sides in a war
it's you got war criminals
and then whoever wins gets to prosecute
the other one going how could you be
such a piece of [ __ ] and everybody kind
of did the same [ __ ]
that's what i was saying the bow and
arrows with the babies basically when
[ __ ] goes down like babies die
it's unavoidable
does this make any sense is this [ __ ]
horrific
i'm like 300 pages down this [ __ ]
road and you guys haven't read the book
yet
so you're probably looking at me like
i'm a maniac why the [ __ ] is it so hot
in here
um
anyways
hopefully i'm able to get this podcast
up on time you know last week i recorded
it on time and there was something
going on with the goddamn recording wow
who's kid knew
you know what that something was it was
me so i actually recorded it on sunday
and still couldn't get it up until
[ __ ] monday afternoon i'm the worst
all right what have we talked about oh
yeah so i started reading up on all this
this stuff about the uh the the war with
the japanese and [ __ ] and i didn't
realize do you know there was like three
guys
three japanese soldiers that didn't
surrender until 1974.
one of them wasn't aware that the war
wasn't over
we'll call him uh bill
that's some [ __ ] i would have done
um the other two guys knew the war was
over but they were like i'm not [ __ ]
standing down until the
the [ __ ] grand poobah tells me to
because that's what i was told when i
went they just were like dudley do
rights
these [ __ ] maniacs
stayed in the woods for an extra 30
years
in their uniform their guns still worked
they still had ammunition of course you
did the [ __ ] war is over and every
once in a while they run at some local
fishermen and they take shots at them
and local fishermen are just like come
on man
let it go man it's over they would drop
leaflets in there and they were reading
them and they thought it was a trick
oh my god you're sitting out there
[ __ ] eating squirrels for 30 goddamn
years
you know best friends like a [ __ ]
what would you be friends with out there
i don't know i'll give you the link to
that [ __ ] before i just butcher it
anymore
um if anybody else knows any really good
books about world war ii where it's
really balanced
um
because i i read a few i read this one
that was great uh i read the rape and
nan king a long time ago
i read this hiroshima diary about this
guy who was
in that city when the bomb hit
uh
i ran another one
i like those first part like people who
were there i read one one time about
this jewish kid
who was on the run with his dad
it's a classic too i forget what the
[ __ ] it was called i'm such an idiot
but at one point he was kind of looking
at his dad he was just like just die
already because he was i don't know
slowing him down or something he has
guilt about that she was [ __ ] unreal
actually it's kind of depressing when
you think about it but um
now it dude gives a [ __ ] hey i got all
caught up in breaking bad i didn't have
amc in my hotel so i came here i just
binge watched all [ __ ] three of them
jesus christ
is that the greatest [ __ ] show ever
i don't want to over hype it but uh
it's [ __ ] insane i'm not going to
talk about i don't i shouldn't i should
have said right out of the back that i'm
not going to say anything that happens
in them
but um
i didn't think anything was going to
beat the wire
i guess they put them on par because the
wire just the
size of the subject and how many
different angles they hit it from
but as far as keeping your stomach and
absolute [ __ ] nuts
uh i don't know if i ever saw a show
like like this one man
um
it's kind of funny because i always have
like quick little scenes in them
and that's all they would ever give me
is just like the little scene so i don't
know what i don't know what's going on
which is kind of perfect because my
character doesn't need to know doesn't
need to know what is going on and
wouldn't know
right saul would just call me up and say
hey just [ __ ] do this and i'd be all
right
so
i always end up watching the episodes oh
that's what the [ __ ] that was for
um that happened this week
all right so anyways hey how about the
red sox huh coming out to la beating the
[ __ ] dodgers
i would have loved to go into a game
down there and war not wore any red sox
[ __ ] because [ __ ] la fans are such
[ __ ] psychopath
well maybe they actually maybe they
wouldn't have beaten me because i wasn't
there with my children
[Laughter]
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
good god almighty
you know i don't know what the [ __ ] i
don't know what happened out here
i don't get it i don't get why that's
that extra level
that gang bang or vibe is out here
there's gangs every [ __ ] city
are these like in la like these the only
or southern california i should say
because i felt that vibe at a chargers
game too like is is this like the only
part of the country where gang bangers
are into like sports too
you know
you think you get some hard looks at a
[ __ ] knicks game you don't
everybody's there having a good time
i don't understand it
they're gonna have something to do with
neck tattoos
once you get the neck tattoo
i'd say i was [ __ ] up when i was in
new orleans i saw two guys with face
tattoos and i couldn't believe how
uh
unshocking they were at this point i've
seen so many people have faced tattoos
at this point this guy literally had one
right in the middle of his forehead and
it wasn't a good one
you know
jesus christ i thought i was dedicated
to being a comedian or whatever you put
a tattoo on your face i mean that
you've limited yourself to
like either working in a tattoo parlor
or doing just illegal [ __ ]
right
that's kind of a good way you know if
you ever think that you don't you don't
you don't have the balls
to stop following the herd just get a
nice
you know what don't do it don't don't do
it i don't want to suggest you get a
[ __ ] face tattoo
please don't do that can can you please
not do that
um did i mention i was at the university
of cincinnati
last night saturday night by the time
you get this it'll be two nights ago i
want to thank everybody for having me
out there what a [ __ ] beautiful
school that is
absolutely gorgeous man i love those
those they have like the perfect size
football stadium and it's like built
down in it so
into the campus you know so you come
walking by and it's really open like you
can just walk right into it
um i had that same vibe like when i went
down to florida state i like the
students can like you know run the
stairs if they want to
i love that [ __ ] i hate when you go to
those places and they got the stadiums
like all locked up
um
i was surprised when i went to boise
you know when i was trying to look at
the the blue turf i saw a little bit of
it that the whole stadium was just
locked up like that i think it boise is
a cool place right
what are you worried about
the meth heads coming in stealing the
aluminum benches
is that what it is it probably is i
don't know
oh by the way i want to thank rolling
stone magazine for putting me on the
cover this month
it finally happened for me that was a
big moment my career
i hope we'll definitely have a link
i know a lot of people don't read
magazines at this point so it's not a
big deal but it's a big deal to me
finally being on the cover of uh
of rolly stone
um
actually i don't have no idea who that
kid is but it [ __ ] freaked me out
when i saw it
um all right
what am i talking about here
what do i got here i'm gonna go do the
uh let's read it let's read a [ __ ] uh
read one of these things here
why don't we do that
why don't we read a little [ __ ]
letter
full moon mr burr
you mentioned something about the full
moon in last week's podcast and how it
causes strange behavior
i worked in an emergency room for three
to five years and when i started working
there i thought the theory was [ __ ]
he actually said both i don't want to
make this guy sound crass he goes i now
know
i now know it to be true every month
during the week of the full moon we get
a surge of patience
other than the
a plethora of fatties that clog our
department
he spelt it pluthera
uh we get weirdos example a one-legged
schizophrenic man with a suitcase of
knives
and a butane torch i don't even i don't
even know why
other than the other than the weirdos
though we have a lot of really sick
patients coming there are more strokes
heart attacks and other serious health
related issues i've recently heard a
theory on why this is from another
health care professional well thank god
you went in this direction buddy because
i thought for half a [ __ ] second you
were going to put this in my lap
all right because i have no clue
about any of this [ __ ]
um
all right what do we got here he goes i
i too take a lot of what i hear as fact
all right the theory is the theory is
this even our blood has its own tide
jesus christ why don't i read up on
science this is like better than any
[ __ ] movie just the truth
what do you mean it has its own tide
when it goes out is that when i get
light-headed is that what you're talking
about
uh he goes this may be minuscule i love
that you're spelling all these words
wrong and you [ __ ] work in an
emergency room
but the lunar pole on our bloodstream
can cause a person with health heart
problems
to be at a higher risk for stroke slash
heart attack
it can also cause behavioral changes
because of the change in our bodily
function in our body function whether
this is true or not i cannot deny three
and a half years of dealing with
hell every week the full moon appears
thanks for the free imitate
entertainment and the laughs so that's
really interesting so like
if that's true so when there's a full
moon that's like uh when society's like
uh menstruating
that's our once a month
like everybody just acts like a [ __ ]
maniac
a one-legged schizophrenic with a
suitcase full of knives and a butane
torch
jesus christ doesn't that sound that
sounds like uh what the [ __ ] was that
movie mickey rourke was in that
looked like a cartoon but it wasn't
jessica alba had the chaps on
she was a stripper but she still looked
like you could have her as a girlfriend
and it was that guy with the yellow head
and the red eyes
for some reason remind me of the guy who
played beretta
do you know i saw him when i was out
here
i saw robert blake
that's a hell of a thing run into a guy
who [ __ ] killed somebody
or did he get off
i don't know he [ __ ] did it jesus
christ you're going to do a spaghetti
freddy's you know you go to take a piss
and all of a sudden your girlfriend's
shot in the head
and nobody saw anything
and you found her come on come on
beretta
for reals
come on
um all right wisconsin's a-rod yo billy
redface love the podcast and i would
love to paint another picture of the
a-rod story all right my version is with
no ryan braun
i live in wisconsin where aaron rodgers
and the green bay packers are basically
a gift from god i am a chicago bears fan
so i think basically
so i think they're all [ __ ] sorry i'm
really reading worse than usual
um all right braun who also got pop for
peds had opened two restaurants with
aaron rodgers called the eight to 12
or 812 mbp bar and grill since they are
both
named mvp in their respective sports and
i'm gathering that his number is eight
is he a baseball player i don't watch
baseball
uh when the news broke about braun
getting suspended wisconsin was enraged
not so much that he was cheating or
being the bad image to kids or whatever
these parents who want to blame other
others for the their kids lack of luster
or athletic skills but because he lied
to aaron rodgers
that's [ __ ] awesome
the wisconsin has some great sports fans
and i love the fact that their their fan
base owns a part of the team however the
[ __ ] that works even though you know
none of them are allowed in the board
meeting
it's probably just by name only and
someday they'll realize how bad they got
fleeced
um anyways in the past month or so when
it came to the news reporting this
reporting this story local nbc abc fox
and cbs affiliates within 10 seconds
into the story they talk about lying to
aaron rodgers when interviewing fans
about it all they talk about is i can't
believe he would lie to us and even lie
to aaron like everyone knows each other
on a personal level people need to quit
talking taking professional sports too
seriously and taking it personally uh
especially when they are
multi-millionaires lying to other
multi-millionaires google search some of
this to get a laugh at how brainwashed
sports fans of my state are come to show
milwaukee during the football season to
see for yourself i've been up there it's
[ __ ] great thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
um
well look i mean he how how did he lie
to aaron
they they got in business together
you know it's not like uh
he got on their football team
and then he said well you know i'd like
you to join the packers as long as
you're steroid free they open the
business together i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do just don't steal from the
register that would be more lying to
aaron rodgers right
or do you think he actually sat down and
said well listen
i have a great image
you know last thing i needed to be doing
is hitching my wagon to some guy who's
then going to be a uh you know
you know [ __ ] hookers and uh
everybody somebody stick a needle in his
f
i you know what i've never opened a
business as you can tell i don't know i
don't know what how the interview
process goes
but i don't yeah i don't feel like he
lied to aaron
um
maybe maybe they actually came up with
this maybe this is a good cop bad cop
thing they're doing
where this other guy plays the bad guy
and then aaron sits at the bar looking
all dejected and the cheeseheads walk by
and then they come in and they buy more
[ __ ] mozzarella sticks
you know that that could happen right
i don't [ __ ] know
who gives a [ __ ] you know what the
[ __ ] thing is and i'm telling you i'm
pulling a paul versi and i said this
three years ago
within 20 years everybody's going to be
on steroids everybody's going to be on
hgh okay
we're all going to be on it they're
going to [ __ ] get it to the same way
weed is gradually becoming legal that's
what's going to happen with roids
all right and now how also if you smoke
weed now
if you have a vaporizer you're just
basically inhaling just the [ __ ] that
gets you high
all right so it's doing way less damage
than sitting down drinking a bunch of
budweisers like i did on that fan bow
out in the [ __ ] bayou
they're gonna do that with roids back in
the day you did some [ __ ] roids right
your balls shrunk up and you went and
you punched a horse in the in the
[ __ ] face
that's what happened and now they're way
more mellow
although [ __ ] jerry remy's kids
snapped
i don't know jesus christ that's another
[ __ ] boston story
you know when all these all these uh
stories came out
all this [ __ ] that's happened recently
i was actually thinking well you know
this is the balance
we had such an unbelievable decade it
has to balance it out
you know with all this horrible [ __ ]
happening now and it's like no wait a
minute no it was nothing but horror
so with those championships that made us
even
so now there's some horrible [ __ ] coming
these last couple years so you know what
that means we're going to win some more
championships coming up
that's how i look at it oh by the way um
any san francisco 49er fans listening to
this how do you feel about old [ __ ]
kaepernick out there [ __ ] on the
cover of every magazine half naked with
his [ __ ] ass in the air showing off
his tattoos and his abs doing
commercials and all that type of [ __ ]
you think he won the [ __ ] super bowl
have you seen one goddamn commercial
with joe flacco
huh
have you
i haven't
as a football fan i don't like when that
[ __ ] happens
i'll tell you right now once tom brady
started experimenting with his haircuts
and walking around with uggs going to
fashion shows
i don't know we have won one sense
doesn't that sound like some typical
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you'd hear on sports
talk radio
the renaissance i had when i was in
boston was tuned to sports talk radio
and i i i can't [ __ ] listen to it
it's just the d i was i put it on
and they were criticizing big papi
saying he's a selfish player you know
it's classic boston [ __ ] morons
sports fans where it's just inevitable
they're going to eat their own
you mean the guy who [ __ ] helped was
one of the main factors in ending
that curse the 86 year curse of the babe
all of that [ __ ] horse [ __ ] that guy
should be able to [ __ ] in the street for
the rest of his [ __ ] life
not even 10 years later you're already
saying that the guy's selfish
shame on you boston sports talk radio
shame on you
all right let's get back to the podcast
here sorry guys
um so i'm actually predicting uh you
guys might have a little bit of a
hangover there in san francisco
your coach is putting on weight
right
filling out those dockers more and more
every week
trying to will
his people to win
actually i think kaepernick is going to
do great but i always get nervous with
quarterbacks who run around like that
eventually those linebackers they get
sick of that [ __ ] and uh they get an
open shot at you and they uh next thing
you know you're bleeding into your lung
um advice for a skinny guy
all right here we go
hey there billy boy first first time
long time thanks for all the laughs
there no worries all right it's great
that you're helping out those who are
overweight
by shaming them is that what you're
saying i've helped out a couple i've
probably had other people have their
face in a bucket of kfc right now
uh but if i may i'd like to ask for
advice for a guy who's a little on the
thin side of the spectrum
i'm tall six foot seven and weigh around
155 160 pounds dude i can't [ __ ] help
you
you're six seven one fif i weighed 155
in high school and i swear to god i look
like i was gonna get blown down the
street
jesus christ dude
even though i eat quite a bit and eat
regularly
i even also have protein slash meal
supplement drinks in between
dude don't [ __ ] drink those things i
don't know [ __ ] about them but don't
drink those things
that [ __ ] powder thing that comes
into that
that breaking bad [ __ ] oil drum
don't don't do that dude
all those supplements and all that type
of [ __ ] don't [ __ ] do that
all right
just accept who you are we all want to
look up a little bit better all right
believe me
trust me on this one you're gonna fill
out
all right it happens
whether you want it or not so enjoy the
fact that you can kind of eat whatever
the [ __ ] you want to but i i
my gut tells me to
i don't [ __ ] around with [ __ ] like that
that creatine and that that [ __ ]
muscle milk stuff and all that [ __ ] you
turn it around the back you can't even
pronounce half the [ __ ] that's in it
there's no [ __ ] way that that stuff's
good for you
there's no way that that thing's it's
gonna be better for you than sitting
down eating a nice grass-fed [ __ ]
steak there
um
granted i don't know [ __ ] about
nutrition but i'm also not a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right
anyways he goes my siblings are just as
tall as i am and they are not thin like
me i'm also 23. is it metabolism dude
i'm not a doctor i don't know will i
pass this stage
i don't know
i am somewhat comfortable with myself
and i have a smoking girlfriend of five
years well go [ __ ] yourself then dude
come on
who loves me for who i am but wouldn't
mind a few pounds
oh wait a minute is she bringing it up
should i binge on pasta
thanks bill i bought the razors because
of you well i hope the razors work out
for you
jesus christ dude with your height you
probably need to order them twice
um
no dude listen listen listen listen
you got to be who the [ __ ] you are all
right would you ever say to your girl
like hey you know i'd like it if you
lost a few
you can't you know
i don't know if she just made one
comment and forgot she even said it or
she she's literally giving you a body
image but i'll tell you dude one of the
greatest things you can ever do in life
is accept yourself all right and i'm not
saying like hey you know i'm doing
something unhealthy to myself and i
accept it i don't mean that i mean like
accept what the [ __ ] you look like and
uh and and just you know
just be a good [ __ ] and it everything
falls into place
you don't need to go out there and drink
muscle milk any [ __ ] angel hair pasta
you know set your alarm and get up at
three in the morning go eat that [ __ ]
you're 23 years old
you but you're supposed to be in good
shape all right okay so you're a little
[ __ ] underway who gives a [ __ ]
dude you know what you built like you
built like snoop dogg he seems to be
doing fine
you know
um
i i would i would
not try to gain any weight
i wouldn't try to lose any weight i
would just just keep doing what you're
doing all right you're a guy you're six
foot seven you weigh about 160 pounds
you're 23 and you have a smoking hot
girlfriend who loves you for who you are
and she made one [ __ ] comment about
putting a few more pounds off just let
let that
let that go right by you i won't even
worry about that all right
you're a good man you look how you're
supposed to look all right put that
[ __ ] powdered nuclear waste away
i don't know what the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
does to your kidneys or your liver or
whatever but uh
you know
when the ingredients look like the last
name of russian hockey players you know
or the [ __ ] swedes i think the swedes
got the most difficult names that's
that's a good time to [ __ ] you know
the only time to eat [ __ ] like that is
if you're orbiting the earth other than
that you know go to a farmer's market
like a goddamn human being
all right organizing porn
uh bill on a recent podcast you
complained about the difficulty of
searching
porn on the road did i i thought i was
talking about how i wanted to stop
watching porn i might have said that on
a
podcast in the past and you just listen
to it i don't [ __ ] know but recently
i've been trying to cut down on it
i've been trying to watch it only on
sundays
and that's not a slap to the face to
whoever created all of this [ __ ]
it's just
you know sunday's a day of rest
and i like to be totally relaxed
if i can open up to you guys a little
bit i'm sorry all right
anyways he says
as i also have a job that requires me to
travel a lot i know all too well the
frustration of unreliable internet
connections and the sheer amount of time
wasted on searching for the perfect porn
video so let me tell you about a little
trick i recently discovered
paying for porn
i know paying for porn feels
counterintuitive
but it's worth it
um here's what you do well it's the only
reason i don't pay for porn is because i
don't want my credit card on the porn
site and then if they double swipe it i
don't have to call the credit card
company
saying that you know you jizz.com
[ __ ] double swiped my credit card and
i'm really upset by it
or no even worse they'd call me up
you know
you know did you uh [ __ ]
i don't know you can't even come up with
a good [ __ ] did you uh ass bag 9000
did you [ __ ] rent that
no did you rent [ __ ] scat bag on the
ass bag returns
yeah yeah i ordered that one no i'm
kidding
i'm not i'm not into scat everybody
the german kind or the or like the [ __ ]
that scat man cruthers did i i hate ever
tell you how much i hate scat singing
i'll tell you one of the worst scot
singers of all the time would be [ __ ]
frank sinatra at the risk of pissing off
all the italian americans
his scat singing at the end of strangers
in the night
[Music]
he sounded like joe piscopo doing him
before joe even did it right
anyways let's go back to this [ __ ] still
let me tell you what i learned a little
tricky thing uh paying for porn i know
paying for porn feels counterintuitive
but it's worth it here's what you do
find a site that has the kind of content
that you're looking for make sure that
the site allows for downloading and
isn't just streaming only this is key
download all your favorite videos to an
external hard drive
ah jesus christ dude and then what the
fbi kicks open the [ __ ] door and make
sure you cancel your membership before
your 30 days is up or else they'll
charge you again once you've done all
that you'll have a drive full of high
quality porn that you can keep forever
and you don't even need
an internet connection to watch it
jesus christ this guy might have
something figured out here between the
external hard drive that's 50 to 100
and a one month subscription 25 to 30
you're looking at about 80 to 100
initial initial setup
dude that math doesn't work out
you're looking at 75 to 130 dollars
all right you kind of [ __ ] alligator
on both ends of it
whatever i suck at math so no actually i
don't suck at that kind of math i suck
at the kind that you know once you have
to learn how to build a bridge
you know once there were shapes and
there was these paragraphs right you had
to memorize
i even did okay in algebra
if i wasn't such a jerk off i could have
[ __ ] got the c minus not have to go
to summer school but that's a whole
other [ __ ] thing
also i trashed the uh
my teacher at a speech impediment
so i used to make fun of him
that was stupid so when i kind of had a
69 he didn't give me the 70 and he
[ __ ] my summer
um anyways
where am i
you're looking about 800 initial
investment but think of think of all the
time and frustration you'll save by not
having to deal with surfing for porn on
the road it's changed the way i travel
dude you sound like you just bought the
ultimate like neck pillow
pillow however the [ __ ] you say that
word uh by the way i [ __ ] hate those
things you hate when you [ __ ] walk
around the airport those [ __ ]
douchebags have those nick neck pillows
already around the neck i always just
want to punch them right in the nose
it's because they already look like they
have that neck brace on
how [ __ ] lazy are you
you can't hold your head up when you're
walking around
sorry um anyways bill thanks for the
free hours of entertainment they've got
me through countless boring flights and
cab rides well dude so now if i download
my favorite ones well the ones is when i
find one that i really like
i always forget the name of it and then
i can't find it and then i try to search
like these
i try to come up with words that
describe what i watched and it never
comes up like the search engine on these
sites stinks so maybe that's a reason to
do it
uh
and also if i want people to pay for my
[ __ ] dvds
shouldn't i be paying these porn stars
aren't i being a hypocrite god damn it i
think i think i've convinced myself
through you trying to convince me
people i think it's high time
how come lars didn't our falrick didn't
speak out about that
well i guess it wasn't happening to them
back in the day ah jesus i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about here
um all right overrated underrated for
the week everybody guys using the term
[ __ ] to refer to his male friend
that's overrated as in what a
as in what up [ __ ]
oh jesus guys say that to each other
that sounds terrible he said a kid
i hadn't talked to in a while
whom i was supposed to meet up with in
new york city drop this on me and not
only did i tell him i didn't want to
hang out i told him i
wanted to connect my knuckles to his
teeth in a way that would send them
across times square
uh yeah that's bad
what up [ __ ] that doesn't sound that
that sounds like something one white
frat guy would say to another white frat
guy
you know and then do some bastardized
version of some gangster site
right
i got i got a i have an underrated for
you everybody
watching reruns of tj hooker
tj hooker
is arguably the worst acting
ever
on any show that ever happened
or at the very least i would put it up
there all right well let's say you had
the march madness
of worst tv shows
right that anybody ever acted on tj
hooker without a doubt would be a number
one seed in in one of the regions
without they would be like duke
it's [ __ ] horrific
first of all was the episode i saw
him and the armenian dude or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is who's pretending to
be italian
uh
romano
they get separated and they're on
walkie-talkies and somebody's shooting
at t.j hooker and romano is going into
he's
calling tj hooker and i don't know why
he's not saying tj he just he's just
going hooker
and then they'd show [ __ ] tj hooker
with his [ __ ] awful toupee where half
the show it doesn't even match his
[ __ ] sideburns
more gunplay more gun play and they cut
back to romano again and he goes hooker
and then
[ __ ] captain kirk any chance he gets
to fondle and get cheap feels on heather
locklear he does it
he rescued her one time and he was
literally like caressing her face
just for like [ __ ] the final like 90
seconds of the show was just just
rubbing to her the side of her face and
you could tell she's like a young
actress and she doesn't know how to say
in between takes like hey do you want to
do me a favor and maybe just have your
hand on my shoulder just for a second
yeah because it's i just don't feel like
your character and my character that's
how you talk your way out of somebody
doing something weirdness scene and she
doesn't know how to do it
just imagine them running around in
larry bird's short shorts because they
do that also
and captain kirk is sucking in his
[ __ ] stomach whatever don't don't
don't don't listen to this here just sit
down and watch it if you can find it
on your on your cable i'm telling you
unbelievably underrated uh by the way
by the way my tickets came
my tickets came for [ __ ] texas a m
uh alabama college station
me dude i called it paul verzi and uh
two of my other buddies outside of the
business are gonna go to the game and uh
we're taking some [ __ ] uh
i'm doing a couple of gigs oh i had this
right i'm doing el paso
part of the billy red state tour
and then i'm doing um
uh
san antonio i've never i've never been
to either one of those
either one of those states um states
either one of those cities in that state
so i feel like at this point
when i perform in those two i've hit
them all
right i've been to dallas
houston
austin
san antonio el paso
the [ __ ] else is there
i went to a game at the cotton bowl
right
i'm going to go see texas a m who else i
got to see i got to see texas tech i got
to see the longhorns at some point but i
went to the red river game so i saw them
i saw him play oklahoma
i gotta go to i gotta go [ __ ] pig
hunting down there you wanna go pig hunt
we'll [ __ ] do it buddy
we got the biggest [ __ ] pig fake fig
i got it it's big we're in texas i get
it
um
yeah oh yeah by the way you know what um
now that i'm i'm done with my my my
[ __ ]
my glee shoot there
i told you what it was it's called black
and white comes out next year i'm not
gonna bore you with it because uh it's
not gonna come out until next year but
when it does oh oh
golly gee
i'm gonna hopefully get uh the director
mike binder
who's uh one of my favorite comics when
i was growing up
i hope they'll get them on the podcast
here
all right hang on a second let me go to
my website here what's your website bill
oh it's billboard.com thank you for
asking thank you for being interested
isn't that sweet of you all right here's
some of my upcoming shows that i have
uh because i had to move around the red
uh the billy red state tour
um oh would you look at that
all right tuesday night i'm
co-headlining i'm opening for brian
regan
that's already sold out at cobb's comedy
club all ticket proceeds uh go to
charity
um
which i don't know i i pitched it to him
i always wanted to work with him
and i was like come on man you know i'll
open for you we'll get shit-faced
afterwards and he goes yeah we'll give
the money to charity [ __ ] it let's do it
so hopefully if this goes well i'm going
to start doing that with some other guys
i'd like to work with you know
i'd like to do like i'd like to work
with other [ __ ] headliners that i
love and i never get to see
because they're always out headlining
right i'd like to do that with a couple
others and just do them and you know
and then just do shows in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere
um all right so here we go
september 4th
a rescheduled billy red state
extravaganza at the boulder theater
september 5th i'm going to the broncos
game why not opening game of the nfl
season september 6th i'm at the pike
peak center
colorado springs colorado that's also a
red state re-booking
and then i got uh the spotlight 29
casino in coachella california on
september 7th
and i'll read the next week after that
i'm at the abraham chavez theater in el
paso texas that's a red state one
and then because i'm on my way over to
[ __ ] college station why not stop
at the lilac cockrell theater in san
antonio texas i hope i said that right
i've never been there i heard it's
[ __ ] great
and um
paul versi will be on both of those
um those colorado dates in the uh
spotlight casino will have rose bowl
legend and cook
jason lawhead who's just growing by
leaps and bounds it's one of my favorite
things that i'm watching in the business
right now the [ __ ] guy is hilarious
uh try and come out to those shows um
that is it and that's the podcast for
this week i was supposed to mention at
the top of the podcast because i know i
have some new listeners
uh if you like my [ __ ] and you'd like to
see my new stand-up special that came
out last year uh
or did it come out this year last year
came out you people are all the same you
can download it for five bucks
or you can get your very own hard copy
uh dvd version for 20 bucks delivered
right to your [ __ ] house wherever the
hell you live
whatever country i don't give a [ __ ] all
right you can do that billboard.com
click on the uh what is the merchandise
button so what it is
march click on march that's it all right
that's the podcast for this week have a
great week
don't put that pottery [ __ ] in your
goddamn drink all right don't do it
okay go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you
next week
you